حصريا قناه العربيه والحدث في مركز قياده
القوات الشيشانيه في مدينه خرسون هذا كان
مركز القياده للقوات الشيشانيه والقوات
الروسيه المتميزه في مدخل مدينه خرسون
ايضا هناك يوجد المستشفى الذي كان يتم فيه
علاج الجرحى من مناطق العمليات من مناطق
تمركز القوات في القرى والمناطق القريبه
من هنا
الروس اكثر من نصف القوه كانت من قوات
قدير
هل سقطت عليهم نيازكم من السماء لقد
اجبرناهم على الانسحاب كما ترى تم تدمير
مخزن الاسلحه
الصواريخ الروسيه كانت في هذا المبنى الذي
استولوا عليه من احدى الشركات كانوا
يستولون على المباني التي يرغبون فيها ولا
يفرقون بين المباني الخاصه والمباني
العامه
كانوا يقولون جرحاهم من مناطق العمليه
يمكنك ان ترى ناقلات الجرحى التي تركوها
وهي ملطخه بالدماء في هذا القبو كان ينام
الجنود الروس وفي احد الايام ارسل لنا احد
المواطنين الاوكرانيين بيانات الموقع الذي
يتمركزون فيه فصفنا المبنى ونجى من كان في
القبور اما البقيه فقد قتلوا
جنود الاوكرانيون يستغربون من كما سموها
الدعايه الروسيه بانهم انسحبوا من مدينه
خرسان ويقولون هذا القصف والهجوم المضاد
الذي قادته القوات الاوكرانيه هو الذي
اجبر القوات الروسيه عن التخلي عن مواقعها
والانسحاب الى الضفه اليسرى لنهر جنيفر
والتخلي عن مدينه خرسانه التي تم
استعادتها من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
لقناتيه العربيه والحدث